More than 20,000 species of debris are tracked as they orbit Earth.
However, most of this debris is too small for ground-based sensors to track.
Mounted on the exterior of the International Space Station,...
...the Space Debris Sensor (SDS) collects data on smaller orbital debris.
The SDS consists of three layers.
The first two layers are identical and incorporate acoustic sensors.
These measure the exact time and location of a debris hit and the velocity vector.
The first layer has a resistive grid, which gives an indication of debris size.
The last layer helps determine the impact energy and density of the particle.
The data obtained will help estimate the population of debris smaller than 1 mm,...
...and allow a new set of sensors to be developed...
...and placed in the midst of the debris field above station orbit.
This will help improve the debris detection and characterization technology...
...necessary to protect satellites and human space flight missions.